in India on 13th April 1919 at least
10,000 unarmed men women and children
assembled in Amritsar swore garden
called Jallianwala Bagh it was a
peaceful gathering but Indian Army
officer Brigadier General Reginald Dyer
came to the garden blocked the entrances
and without any warning ordered his
troops to directly fire at these
innocent individuals they shot more than
a thousand rounds official figures say
three hundred and seventy nine people
were killed
it is thought to have been hundreds more
dilator said that the firing was not to
disperse the meeting but to punish the
Indians for disobedience
it was barbarism at its worst da was
rewarded in Britain with twenty six
thousand pounds from a public campaign
and a jeweled sword the victims were
given just five hundred rupees each a
century later the British government has
never apologized for this atrocity the
Jallianwala Bagh Massacre lives in the
heart of every Indian around the world
and with UK India relations so crucial
in the decades ahead
why did Theresa May refuse to apologize
earlier this month when I visited the
garden with my mother as a teenager she
said to me son it was nothing short of
murder
[Music]
Karin first of all thank you so much for
choosing this topic as your debate I
think it's such an important discussion
to have and actually it's part of a
wider national discussion that needs to
be had around Empire in general and the
horrors of Empire a part of British
history that we so often try to sweep
under the carpet and pretend never
happened but yet the repercussions are
still being felt to this very day I
think it's interesting that both Teresa
May and Ava
Kameron have referred to the massacre as
shameful but have not apologized and
actually as you say and I'm not bringing
this to be about brexit at all but you
know once we do if we do leave the EU we
need new trading partners so our
relationship with the Commonwealth has
to change and it has to become one of
partnership and for that to happen
authentically we need apologies for many
of these sorts of massacres that have
happened and and you know you're so
right and I've just come back from India
yesterday and I was there for the
beginning of the largest elections the
world has ever known 900 million voters
in a country 1.25 billion and it's just
remarkable seeing those elections in
action and yet every single day there
was all the election news but the
Jallianwala Bagh massacre was in the
papers in India wherever I went every
single day it means so much to me I say
it was in obviously what what was the
Carney's one fascinate one is
remembering it right and and remembering
the atrocity and saying this should
never ever happen again
but also acknowledging this was the
turning point in India's fight for
independence mark McGann D was spurred
on after this and after 1919 it took
almost three more decades to 1947
for India to gain its independence and
Dogon are in the Modi the Prime Minister
he just said recently today we observe
100 years of the horrific Jallianwala
Bagh Massacre India pays tributes to all
those martyred on that fateful day their
valor and sacrifice will never be
forgotten their memory inspires us to
work even harder to build an India they
would be proud of then you know this is
the thing when I went there with my
mother I mean it brings tears to my eyes
that they were innocent men women and
children they were Hindus Sikhs Muslims
they were there yes Fellini and just
shot down what was there's a lot of the
soldiers who were in the British Army
were Gurkhas and were Sikhs and they
were ordered to shoot on their own
people and what I found hideous about
because I've started to read about it I
knew available I've started to read
about it DJ was the shooting was
happening as they were these weren't
armed rebels they were people who come
from the countryside just to listen to
some political speeches and the shooting
started they were trying to get away
they were trying to get through the
gates they weren't searching on anybody
but but can I just say that sometimes an
apology so long after an event can look
like political expediency but but I
think what is really important historic
is that a country acknowledges its shame
it's past finds in the way Germany did
after the Nazis they've always they've
always said how wrong was in the set of
four decades and I think it's a measure
of a country if you do that and and I
think if the people of India
wants us to apologize if they think
those two words that were we're sorry
would he would then we have to be guided
by them and we have to say sorry let's
see what the Prime Minister says cause
her view is probably more important than
the five of us put together as Her
Majesty the Queen said before visiting
Jallianwala Bagh in 1997
it is a distressing example of our past
history with India we deeply regret what
happened and the suffering caused I'm
pleased that today the UK India
relationship is one of collaboration
partnership prosperity and security
Indian diaspora make an enormous
contribution to British society and I'm
sure the whole house wishes to see the
UK's relationship with India continue to
flourish Teresa may speaking last week
June not for now but you talk about past
Horrors was it horrors of the Empire
it's not all horrific the Empire did
bring some positives the well ending
burning women Indian widows being burnt
when the husband you were to speak to my
ancestors they will say the horrors of
the Empire thank you so that was a good
thing we stopped that I now be quick
before radio just one final point I was
just gonna say can I came into this
debate probably thinking I don't agree
with the parties because I don't know
quite where you'll end because we'll
then to start apologizing what happened
quite respectfully to you well then and
I've been completely moved by the way
you've put this so I came in thinking
I really like candies got this one wrong
I shut it you're right so credit to you
I've moved completely because what you
said well Mike my concern is that an
apology is too easy a sticking-plaster
to put on some ass car that is obviously
so deep and so terrible for India and
perhaps I mean I'm trying to be generous
here to the lack of apology given by our
politicians in succession from Theresa
May when she went to India in 2016 two
trees may in the Commons just then and
two are to the High Commissioner in
India Dominic Asquith who also refused
to say sorry and just said that he
regretted the regret cause less
hefferman the revulsion that we felt at
the time is still strong today it
tarnished the reputation and we regret
as I say the suffering and will continue
to do so the suffering caused if an
apology helps to make it better and
India insists and wants and deserves an
apology then we should give an apology
what I do you wanted to say it's a very
quick point and Prince Charles went to
Ghana this year and demonstrated how you
do this properly
he was a elmina castle at the slave fort
and he apologized he apologized for
Britain's role and all that was done to
the hundred thousands of slaves that
were taken out of that country and you
see this is the thing there is a
precedent for making apologies I went
with David Cameron to India in 2013 he
went on to Amritsar many of us said
please apologize or to make a huge
difference he didn't do it you know on
the other hand on the other hand the
Bloody Sunday in 2010 he wouldn't he
didn't but he he absolutely apologized
to Bloody Sunday Gordon Brown apologized
for the children who were sent away to
Australia Justin Trudeau has apologised
for the shrimp
100 years ago that was turned away from
Vancouver so there is precedent and I
agree it should not be a sticking
plaster and we should also learn from it
we must have British children must learn
about this India of course it's as in
the heart of every Indian there's the
learning but the apology will go such a
long
and I would do it straightaway people in
India count who don't want the the the
India Telegraph they did a piece and
they just think can the present
generation in Britain be truly held
accountable for what was perpetrated by
members of a colonial apparatus even
while conceding the possibility that
some of the descendants are in a
position of privilege on account of
their energy this is this is very
important
would a mere apology suffice as
compensation for the humongous scale of
violence and exploitation that India has
endured as a colony but no I think the
words sorry if you know somebody I read
one piece this someone said better than
saying sorry why don't we invite and the
descendants children and mothers and
fathers of people who were were killed
in the massacre India to this country
you know let them live be educated yeah
that's that's better than just saying
two words I'm sorry so this is not
either all the sorry is absolutely
essential and will go a long way because
got a great future ahead of us Britain
and India the fifth and sixth largest
economies in the world and India being
growing and growing for the decades to
come but then you get into things like
reparations
you know trillions of pounds are
supposedly taken from India by the
Empire but then there was a lot of good
that the Empire did as well and it's an
argument my friend strategy to rule the
former Indian Finance Minister wrote a
book in glorious Empire and from his
point of view one pound is a token
reparation token token just the gesture
would in his view be go a long way so I
think the apology will go a long long
way yeah and I completely agree